well now some big name actors are  raising their voices to oppose  this new reign of terror this is actor  brian cranston  we live in this cancel culture of  people uh airing  and doing wrong  either on purpose or by accident  isn't it possible that that forgiveness  plays a part in that  and they are welcomed back in as opposed  to  creating more fences creating more you  make  you make one mistake gone  you know laura like a number of  comedians we've heard from in recent  days uh the mandalorian star gina carano  and others  these artists are concerned about their  own endangered expression  look they face cancellation as well  rowan atkinson recently said  we now have the digital equivalent of a  medieval mob  roaming the streets looking for someone  to burn i couldn't agree more  and good for these artists for speaking  out it's divisive  and it's destructive to a society and it  ain't a lot of fun  that's the most important still